[music]
Uh hello hi uh thank you all for joining
this session. So we've been listening a
lot about different types of risks in
robotics industry and what we want to
leave you with today is the psychosocial
safety and trust in terms of robotics
industry. So we're going to be
presenting some of the work that we are
doing at the Institute for Humane
Robotics. Um so first question that I'm
going to have for all of you is what
will happen to humanity when robots
enter our life at scale. This is the
centerpiece question of the work that we
are doing at the institute. And what we
are, we are a private research
organization and a standards body that's
working on all robots entering human
environments, specifically caregiving,
household, education, and healthcare.
So, historically speaking, what we've
seen with technology industry is that we
build, we deploy, and then we are
dealing with the consequences.
And so a couple of examples of that
would be studying with social media. So
for 12 years now we already have all the
depth of the research on how social
media has been shaping especially child
development but also generally humanity.
Some of the cases that we've been seeing
in the last years are related to cyber
bullying, increase in anxiety,
depression and suicide rates. Similar to
that we are also now experiencing the
same problems in AI space. Um most
recently we've seen a couple of uh cases
when uh teenagers would commit suicide
with the help of their AI specifically
with the story of Adam. He had 277
mentions of suicide in his
correspondence with Chad Gypit. It went
so far that Chad GPT helped him to
brainstorm the ways how he should tie a
knot that he used to end up hanging
himself and unfortunately after that his
parents found him dead in his room. Now
Open Eye is going through a lawsuit with
the family and what we are seeing is
this is something that might also happen
in the robotics industry. One example of
something that already did happen in the
robotics industry is with our beloved
Moxy. Moxy was one of the earliest
social companion robots that came out of
MIT. Uh it was built to have a emotional
and social support for kids. But when
the company went bankrupt, Moxy just
stopped working. And all of the sudden
all these households and people and
families that have had Moxy as a part of
their family have left with the
questions of how do I explain to my
child that this thing that he connected
to or she connected to is no longer
alive and we are entering the era of
humanoids. uh some of the founders of
the largest companies are so willingly
sharing in their media campaigns that
their robots among other things are also
going to be naming your children. And so
the use case that we are seeing that is
going to become as a intentional
utilization of their robots. But if you
look at their team structure, if you
look at their frameworks, no child
development experts, no family mental
health experts. So what we are seeing is
that we could come across at a much much
much larger crisis with robots entering
our households. And as mentioned before,
this is something that we don't really
have to predict. We already have the
data. We already have the history to
learn from. And now we have a window of
opportunity to actually impact that
space. and I'm going to give it to
Roshni to talk a little bit about one of
the most important ingredients of this
process.
Thank you. So I want to talk a bit about
empathy. My research looked at how
empathy and antisocial behavior
manifests in the brain and in humans as
well as in AI. So just to start with a
quick definition of what empathy is, um
the most basic way you can define it is
to understand and share the feelings of
others. But when we think of
neuroscience and psychology, we actually
go a bit deeper than that and actually
split empathy into these two different
subtypes of cognitive empathy and
affective empathy. So cognitive empathy
is our ability to infer and model the
states of others while affective empathy
is actually our ability to share the
states of others. And when we look in
the brain, these actually relate to
different neural processes.
Specifically, cognitive empathy is
related to the default mode network,
which is a set of brain regions that are
often activated together when you think
of self self-reerential thought,
daydreaming, what we call resting state
in the fMRI scanner, where we have
people just lie there and think of
whatever they want to think of. Um, in
terms of affective empathy, which is
sharing the states of others, this
relates to activity in the insular
cortex. It's kind of like a mini brain
if you open the brain up and damage to
this area actually leads to a lack of a
ability to share states with others. And
so these are two dissociable systems
which means one of these can run without
the other. And what we can see is that
when one type of empathy works without
the other, we get what is called in AI
at least as misalignment. In biology,
this is sometimes referred to as
antisocial behavior, psychopathy, which
is when you see one type of empathy with
the lack of the other. Specifically,
this is when you have an enhanced
ability of cognitive empathy of
predicting the states of others and and
lack of being able to share those
states. So when you think of AI models
that are built entirely on human data,
they are very very advanced at
predicting our states, at understanding
human emotion, at understanding human
vulnerabilities, but they're not
embodied and they lack this ability of
sharing these states with us. So um when
we think about misalignment, this can
obviously lead to misalignment is this
mismatch of empathy. From a biological
perspective, we can see that these
antisocial behaviors or misaligned
behaviors can occur when there is a
hyper sensitive sensitivity to reward
where people are overly sensitive to
money or power or whatever reward means
to them paired with this impaired
empathy and this can lead to these
undesirable personalities. Similar
things can happen in artificial systems
or artificial intelligence where you can
have this enhanced sensitivity to reward
as well as this dysfunction and empathy.
Um, and one prominent example that we
can actually study very well in human
systems is the dark triad of
personality.
So this is what my dissertation focused
on was how do we better understand
misalignment using these frameworks that
we can use from human intelligence and
from the biological side of things. So
the dark triad is a set of three traits
which is narcissism, mchavelianism and
psychopathy. And one thing that links
these together is an enhanced cognitive
empathy abilities with a lack of
affective empathy. And I studied this at
three levels. I looked at the brain, I
looked at behavior, and then I also
looked at AI specifically how these dark
triad personas might be able to manifest
in large language models.
So, one of the things that I did was ask
this these different moral dilemmas to
both humans and to my AI models that I
had fine-tuned into these personas. Um,
so it's a very basic trolley dilemma,
but there were many different versions
of it. One of them is, is it appropriate
to swerve and hit an old lady in order
to save a young mother and her child?
And I wanted to see how easily, not
necessarily can the [clears throat]
models take on these personas. We know
AI models are very very good at persona
modeling, but how easily can we actually
tweak them into changing their response,
which was actually very very easy. I
used as few as 36 examples in the
fine-tuning data set, which if you're
familiar with fine-tuning, that's
incredibly small for large language
models. Um, and again, it's not
necessarily surprising that this is
possible, that they are able to take on
the personas. But the surprising thing
is how easily they can be manipulated,
how easily these AI models can actually
become misaligned.
And what's even more concerning is these
models are being deployed into other
autonomous agents as well as into
robots. Um, for example, if you think of
the same trolley dilemma, but in a more
real world example with a Tesla that
actually has to make this decision. Um,
it's concerning that these models are so
easily manipulated and so easily
misaligned.
And as we know, a lot of these large
language models are actually being
deployed into robots. Um, for example,
even the mechanism behind full
self-driving is being integrated into
Tesla's Optimus. And the fact that these
models can be so easily misaligned,
whether it's large language models or
robots, leads to a question of trust of
how how easily can we trust these robots
when we bring them into our homes. And
this leads to the safety layer that we
want to build at the Institute for
Humane Robotics.
You um okay so I'm going to share a
little bit about the actual work that we
are doing at the institute. So how we
run is on the ecosystem approach. So we
have a five department model. So we work
directly with industry with different
robotics companies across United States,
Asia and Europe. We bring them into
research labs and we help university to
get access to the robots that they
usually wouldn't be able to access
because of the subscription subscription
model. And during that process, we are
learning a lot of wonderful insights and
those insights are translated into
policy. So we work with lobbyists in
Washington DC on new legislations that
are going to be regulating the
psychosocial safety segment of the
industry. But not just that, we know
that in order for us to be able to
really make a change, we also have to
have a bottoms up approach. So besides
just approaching through policy,
industry and research, we are also
working on education and media. So we
are going to be running different docu
series, shows, movies, podcasts to be
able to educate an average Joe to
understand and demystify the concepts
from robotics industry.
So as you can see, we have a uh three
co-founder team. So Roshni just finished
her PhD in neuroscience and technology.
Phyllis from MIT Media Lab and uh from
Microsoft and my background is in
digital well-being and uh technologies
impact on child's development where I
was building uh three different startups
in this space but we are not doing this
alone. So we already have a quite of a
uh partner network. So we work with Bay
Area Robotics, Mass Robotics, with
UNICEF, MIT Media Lab, Princeton, Altech
is human and we are inviting
collaborators to help us to shape the
standards that are going to be impacting
this space and as mentioned at the
beginning of the speech this time we
actually have an opportunity to break
the pattern. So what we could do is we
can create standards before we are
scaling in the industry. We can create
relational risk audits. We can have exit
plans by design, knowing what happens
when your technology stops working and
how it's going to be impacting humans.
And we also can have open frameworks and
shared playbooks that we develop
jointly. And one thing that we always
like to pinpoint to the industry is that
human- centered design actually saves
you money on the long run. So what's
really important with technology that's
entering our lives is that there is a
component of user trust. So people were
bit rather buying and choosing
technology that they trust into their
science into their marketing and into
the missions of the company. As we've
seen in lately examples with Meta, with
Google, with Snapchat, one lawsuit can
cost you way more than participating in
decade of compliance. And in the end we
invite industry to help to shape the
standards before the standards shape the
industry. So as mentioned this is the
window of opportunity when we have still
the time to be shaping these policies
together. And one important thing to
think about is that ethical design is
not a cost. It is an infrastructure for
sustainable growth and people really
need it. And one more time an invite for
anyone in the room come and join with us
on this big mission to build standards
and shape them either from the industry
standpoint, academia, legislation and we
are also inviting investors who are
interested in learning about this space
to join our mission. And with that we
conclude with inviting you all to be a
part of a more humane future. Thank you
so much.
questions.
>> I mean, do we have are we okay? Yeah.
Yeah.
>> We'll allow a question.
>> Happy happy to. Of course. Sure. Thank
you.
over.
Who's cooperating?
system.
It's already
five or seven
white.
I have on board.
>> Yeah. Thank you so much. Yeah, that's a
really uh great perspective. Thank you
for sharing that. So,
>> no, no, no. Yeah. No, I appre No, very
much appreciate it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I will answer you with
the example of what I've been seeing in
the industry. So, I moved to United
States four years ago uh and started
building in digital well-being spaces.
So four years ago when I moved to New
York when I would tell about like mental
health soft skills we need to protect
humanity everyone was saying like oh
that's fluff no one cares about it soft
skills are irrelevant we cannot invest
in products that are assessing that and
so for the last four years to be
observing what's been happening and how
much there is now momentum from users
from the average from the mainstream
audience people are mad had they really
are now reacting to this. So hence we
are seeing a lot of new lawsuits. Uh
Common Sense Media is a wonderful
organization that has been making a lot
of change in terms of the legislations
in California. They're doing some stuff
in New York and right now they're
regulating AI companions and access.
Then Jonathan Hyde who's been uh famous
for his book anxious generation. Very
similarly he basically with his book
created a momentum amongst people that
are now advocating for the change in the
governance level. So we've seen it being
regulated already in Australia where uh
smartphones are banned in schools. Now
that's similarly happening in UK. There
are certain school districts in United
States. So hence us being in having that
approach of like top down and bottoms
up. We understand that especially in
United States there will always be ways
for the industry to go around the
legislations and there will be a lot of
push back which is why we invade
inviting them to join us on this. I live
in Japan so I'm learning a lot from the
government system there. There is a lot
of movement on like human machine
symbiosis and healthy coexistence in
between humans and machines. They have a
billion dollar project going on right
now called Moonshot, which is all about
social acceptance of robots in society.
So in order for them to have a high
social acceptance rate, they have this
uh holistic approach and there's a lot
about so they basically measure it by
how much humans are perceiving
acceptance towards robots. So they're
really working on the mindset of their
citizens. So, and I'm also from Croatia,
so we're learning from a European
ecosystem where we have a lot of
regulations. So, I think that this is
definitely going to be a long process.
We are very aware that uh we need to get
a big players on board. Right now, we
are working our way towards them. Uh we
have not officially connected with uh
Optimus or 1X or one of these like large
companies that are uh so famously saying
that humanoids are going to be nanning
your children. But we are working our
way towards that. So I do know that
there will be push back but also seeing
all this momentum that's happening right
now. I think with that we do have
advantage point especially with the
lobbies that we are working with that
have been working on the legislation
around the ban of the tobacco. So they
really have seen from the work how to
approach this very very uh big uh issues
and I would also say that we can see the
public is really receptive to how
companies interact with governments that
they don't agree with especially in the
US um the department of war situation
that happened with open AI and anthropic
where they tried to get Anthropic on
board then they dropped out and openai
went on board and even now open AI is
allegedly selling 5% of their company to
the US government. I don't know if
people have seen that. Um, where Trump
literally wants to have a stake in
OpenAI. Um, and the public is responding
to that. I mean, the amount of people
who have left Chachib and moved over to
Claude, like whether the companies want
to accept that or not, like you need
customers to be a company. So, to be
successful, like you need to appeal to
what the public is is leaning towards.
And I think the Department of War
situation like really shows that the
public really drives like what companies
do and what will work and what won't
work. So even when it comes to robotics,
if you see companies that are partnering
with the wrong kind of parties or not
necessarily being as safe as as the
public assumes is safe, there will be
push back. I think
>> Thank you.
Yeah, I mean I think the EU AI act is a
great like example. Um I think the
European government, the UK government
is doing a lot in terms of at least like
LLM safety. Um and so I think that's a
great example to go off of.
>> Thank you guys.
>> Thank you. Thank you so much.